assalamualaikum we're here in potachad
that's about seven kilometers roughly
from serbaniza this is where the
greatest genocide
the greatest genocide
happened after World War II we're going
to look at
the memorial that's been set up look at
some history and bring to light some of
what's been forgotten
and so be with us let's go ahead and
continue our journey here in Bosnia all
these are the the names of the yes all
the names all the names of people who
died here yes from the genocide yes
how many total
coco no foreign
foreign
July
is
foreign
is the name of this area
this is between Severance and bratonix
this was place where it was basically
the United Nations safe Zone
until it became not so safe for these
victims may Allah give them
these people basically oh this is not
people from strabenza which was which is
misconception with most people this is
area which was safe Zone and all the
Muslims from all the places around were
running here
because the Serbian
aggressors were coming and burning their
Villages killing everybody so they were
running away and this was United Nations
safe Zone supposed to be safe
but then we know the unfortunate trends
that happened in a world later that most
of these people who became who came here
were separated men from women and then
women had their own
Destiny after and Men most of the meals
were killed here some of them we see the
grace there some of them they are
staying approximately around 2 000 or we
don't know how many still missing so and
this is now we're about to enter the
museum
we're looking at some of the footages
from those horrible days
and we have some of the descriptions
here it says that
like the goal of these mothers who are
separated which we've seen the picture
here says to protect the Young
Offspring and to find out the first news
about the mail
males from from their families females
and kids and very old people who were
let go through the safe
to the territory which was under control
of the
Bosnian Army this is a former battery
Factory uh it used to be a before during
the war it was based off United Nations
Forces Dutch peacekeepers
uh they were located here
this building building where we are now
uh Dutch soldiers used as
parking space for their vehicles when
celebrities fell under control Army of
Republica subska 11th of July 1995 uh
when refugees arrive here in patachari
Dutch soldiers decide to move out
vehicles and here in this big hole
located five to six thousand refugees
who spent two days and two nights when
Boston and so forth has deported women
and children who stayed outside when
they
separate men and boys then Dutch
soldiers told this group that they had
to go on checkpoint and on that
checkpoint Bosnian set forces separate
men and boys who were here in the bay
same line people who stayed outside and
that is reason why today we use this
whole as as Memorial room
they're in the cemetery you saw the
number of victims of genocides reverence
370 two victims who are who were killed
during the
genocide in celebrities are there in the
cemetery we have a memorial wall with
all the names of victims of general
science reverends and until today here
in the cemetery
here in Portugal we have Barry Charles
6643 victims of genocide and severins
are more than one and a half thousand
people are still missing or they are not
buried here in the cemetery you know
every year on anniversary day here in
Port Richey we have new annual
commemoration a new burial day for new
identified victims of general science
reverence and this year we wear it just
33 victims of China's side
it's a feeling that I just can't you
just gotta imagine you have civilians
innocent men women children
who are running for their lives
who are
thinking
they've come under U.N protection so
imagine that the Dutch Battalion were
there to protect the people who lived
there
they didn't
they should have done
you're coming into a this is this
Factory here as you can see
[Applause]
they're coming into this safe Zone it's
supposed to be a safe zone
of the U.N forces
but it ended
up not being
so safe
so United Nations
you have the the Dutch Holland troops
they are supposed to be protecting
putting their lives on the line
uh it reminds me you know if if it was
the other way around you know when when
someone is God conscious when someone
knows that there's a higher being above
them watching it reminds me of the verse
the Ayah in the Quran where the almighty
God almighty is saying saving one
innocent life is as if you saved all of
mankind so imagine if those people see
when you're Godless when you don't have
the consciousness of your creator
imagine if they had this Consciousness
and they knew and they
were aware of the immense
reward of saving and innocent like they
would have been able to put their lives
on the line to save to prevent the
greatest genocide after World War II
but that's what happens when you
separate and you throw out morality the
ultimate morality and God out of your
life so
that's just what comes to my mind so you
have the safe Zone ended up not being so
safe you have imagined this area now all
of these innocent human beings coming
running for their lives and then what
happens next they start separating the
men's meant the young boys and the men
and then the women we hear women are
being raped and you imagine that
a horrific scene
and we often hear never forget
so
we're bringing this to light
for many who have no idea what happened
here so we can truly never forget to
prevent something like this from ever
happening again again
this guy he admitted that he killed 100
people and he got
five years of prison
as well
so we got a chance to see like this
abandoned Factory and just envisioning
the scene you get to see the war
criminals who were convicted and you get
to see people who are killing one
innocence a man killed a hundred people
can you imagine and he got five years
yes
so then how we came to know most of
these facts is people were coming up
their conscious many were now just
coming up coming forward and they were
giving up the others and saying that
they were forced to do these things
because of their higher ups now we come
over here and we see some of the things
some of the artifacts of what some of
the from Holland the soldiers the U.N
peacekeepers who are supposed to be
protecting the
innocent human beings who sought Refuge
here you can see here what they found in
the wrong walls one writes I'm your best
friend I kill you for nothing this is in
94.
another one here
it's interesting you got the cross here
you have a cross here and he says
killing killing is my business and
business is good
the free man
um
[Music]
naturally
it's interesting that the these uh what
they call the extreme serbs or the
chutneys you never really have their
faith brought up into it but we know
that their guns were being blessed by
priests you never get Christianity
brought into it but they were actually
not only on the part of the nationalism
but also you see these people who are
doing a modern day Crusade now again we
don't blame Christianity
just the same way you cannot go ahead
and if some Fringe element do something
and the person has a name that's that's
connected to Islam has nothing to do
with Islam so we don't blame
Christianity but it's just interesting
that you never see
their religion brought it into it but
you can equate this to a modern day
Crusade that was happening because these
were Christians and they were as you can
see both of them working together and
they let what's supposed to be a safe
Zone a protection for them they let the
greatest genocide after World War II
happen under their watch
oh
your voice
[Music]
assistant
but if this doesn't work Jenna what do
you think it will do to the people
it will work it will work you have here
all the participants
all the people
some of the people that were found
guilty
and
the uh
the main ones here from the president
and the main generals
now these people were Christian
that is undisputable we don't blame
Christianity
I make this point because they were
leading a modern day
Crusade
but you'd
hardly ever if ever hear anyone bring
any
normal person knows
that this has nothing to do
with Christianity the true teachings of
loving your neighbor
I mean it just reminds me of
a passage from the Bible
the gospel of Matthew where one came to
Jesus said oh good Master what good
thing what what good thing can I do that
I may have
inherit the Kingdom meaning how do I get
to Paradise he said why are you calling
me good this is allegedly Jesus saying
why why do you call me good there's none
good but God almighty so here we see
he's just differentiating himself from
God then
he said what else he said then you got
to keep the Commandments and then after
listening a bunch of them he said the
love your neighbor
so this is a great example
for others who are Serbian Christian or
whoever to remember this and to remember
those teachings those true teachings
that you have in your Bible of loving
your neighbor
because if you love your neighbor truly
you will not ever let something like
this
happen again not even thinking about it
let alone coming close to it so these
were
Christians
but we don't blame Christianity and it's
a great lesson because you have much of
the media
that tries to use Muslims Escape ghosts
Islam is a scapegoat so anytime some
lunatic does something
they try to put Islam on the witness
stand and call Muslims terrorists and
spread
this Mass manipulation
of feeding the people these lies
half truths
and what this does is creates fear in
people
and then you attack what you fear and
this is what we saw happen more than uh
20 000 people stayed outside in front of
the base behind the blue building they
were not able to enter in the base there
on the main road there was a checkpoint
for a Boston's surf forces separate
men and boys and first they they sent
them to the house Acres Road is called
White House
where they torture them and then they
deported them to the territory of one's
parties warning where they shooting all
of them
now I want you to Envision it I mean the
United Nations are there to as
peacekeepers and they're supposed to
protect
these innocent non-combatant civilians
and that's why they were running here
you actually had signs that we saw back
over there standing for United nothing
yeah because they did nothing
this is the uh
the head telling everybody that good
news the good news you're all safe
what a liar
okay so what is this now
this is the Dutch soldiers celebrating
in uh Group after they left from Serbia
it's after surveillance I fell
why are they celebrating
well I mean this is I guess the job was
done I don't know
so while the Muslims are being massacred
these guys are celebrating
yeah
that was just after they turned over the
Muslims to this
curse
official delegation including the Dutch
Crown Prince the Prime Minister members
of the parliament had traveled to zargo
the Dutch Army commander-in-chief
insisted on having a party
the evening zabra the beer and the music
contribute to the feelings of relief and
joy among the soldiers who had survived
their mission however survivors and many
others saw it as a totally inappropriate
time for a party
commanders here all these people who
this is one of the beautiful things now
that our Dean teaches that they might be
able to get away with all of this
evil in this life but that's why
there's a day of judgment
and the ultimate Reckoning will be there
and these criminals will be held to
account on the greatest Court in front
of the crater on the day of recommends
the day of judgment
[Applause]
[Music]
we pray for all those innocent human
beings the victims
and their families who had to suffer
this
horrible tragic ordeal
this is the headquarters
the command center
for the
for the U.N
Dutch who was supposed to be protecting
these civilians
[Music]
you get to see live here some of the old
equipment that they were using
this is the actual
headquarters post for this area here the
room
that
they were using
can't show you
many of the pictures on the wall
just provocative pictures of
naked women
many disgusting things
the soldiers were riding on the walls
however this is the state of the human
being
when he doesn't have to call God
consciousness
she was
brings the human down to the
lower than an animal
you can come in these rooms
and you can go ahead and see some
other videos that they prepared this is
the graveyard and Memorial
these are all
human beings
this is human life
that has been taken
and
there's a slogan
here also
that is said never forget never forget
unlike the slogan that we hear
often when we hear never forget we
usually attribute it to 9 11. and what
we say about that is anywhere where
human life
is taken
human life in America human life in
Afghanistan in Bosnia innocent human
life taken
his innocent human life we condemn all
Acts
of evil of terrorism
but here
we know exactly
who those terrorists were who
perpetuated this great
the greatest genocide after World War II
where you had all these people here
they were killed unjustly
so I often say never forget yes never
forget that Islam and Muslims had
nothing to do at all with 9 11. but here
instead of Anita never forget that these
Crusaders
who are actually Christian
and their Theology and ideology is still
stems and is alive
and you had the New Zealand terrorist
who perpetuated that ideology and you
have many others these islamophobes
who are out there trying to revive this
who are trying to
who are actually going away from the
true teachings of Jesus because we know
this does not represent true
Christianity which is about loving your
neighbor
so we need to work together as
human beings who are on this Earth
together
to make it a more peaceful and livable
place for all because there is only one
Creator and he created us all
and he is the one who will judge between
us
so it's not on us to take innocent human
life
that is sacred
according to all
religions especially the way of life
from the crater Islam where it says
killing innocent one innocent human
being is as if you kill the world and if
these Dutch
these people
these U.N forces
would have been implementing
God's
Divine Law
of saving one innocent life is as if you
saved the world they would have not have
let this genocide happen we're here in
San benizza